hi this is pres Harker let's learn how
to play ultimate tic-tac-toe standard
tic-tac-toe is played on a 3x3 grid in
which each of two players alternates
placing X's and O's in squares the first
player to get three in a row wins the
game
ultimate tic-tac-toe is also played on a
3x3 grid but each of these squares also
has a 3x3 grid inside of it since each
3x3 grid has nine possible squares to
play this means this game has 81
different squares where you can place an
X or an O here are the rules of ultimate
tic-tac-toe the first player X can play
anywhere on the board so let's say X
plays in the center square in the upper
left-hand corner now o has to play in a
particular square since X played in the
upper left-hand corner that means o has
to play in the square corresponding to
the upper left-hand corner now since Oh
has played in the upper right-hand
corner X has to play somewhere in the
3x3 grid that's in the upper right-hand
corner and the game continues this way
each time one of the players plays that
forces which square the other player can
play in at some point you might get to a
place always just sent X to play in the
center square which is completely filled
if that happens
X can play in any of the squares so X
may decide to complete a three in a row
here and the play will continue with the
same rules
let's keep filling in the game the first
player to win three in a row in a
particular small game will win that game
and if a player happens to win three of
the games in a row
that's how you win ultimate tic-tac-toe
so you have to win the small square to
win the square and then you have to get
three of the squares in a row so it's a
pretty neat game you should give it a
try
and if people are interested I'll make a
video on how you can have a winning
strategy please subscribe to my channel
I make videos on math and game theory
you can support me on patreon catch me
on my blog mind your decisions on
Twitter at pressure Locker and you can
get my books at Amazon